I'll be going on my day you turn on the
news
here's another our Kelly victim another
our Kelly victim another our Kelly V and
you just you just want to be there for
them one of the anonymous accusers in
our Kelly's criminal case is speaking
out publicly for the first time to CBS
News I know that I love myself today I
know that I don't care what anybody say
about me Kelly has pleaded not guilty to
ten counts of aggravated criminal sexual
abuse involving four alleged victims
lenita Carter is the woman identified in
the indictment as Elsie she used to be
our Kelly's hairdresser and she was just
24 years old at the time of the alleged
sexual assault in 2003 I'm not ashamed
of my past anymore I'm not ashamed of
what they say are saying Carter said she
braided Kelly's hair for more than a
year but saw him as more than just a
client she also considered him like a
big brother
she even stood up for Kelly when he was
arrested on child pornography charges in
2002 Kelly was later exonerated of those
charges so was perfect didn't I would
tell people to pray for him pray for him
I do his hair he is nothing like what
they say Carter alleges that Kelly never
propositioned her or asked her to do
anything sexual until February 2003 I
get a phone call to come down and do his
hair when he came to the room and he
asked me for that head massage and I
told him I didn't do massages I laughed
it off
and I didn't know he was for real if I
continued that I wouldn't been there
Carter continued to describe the alleged
assaults claiming he only stopped after
someone knocked on the door he didn't
open the door right away
he says fix your face fix your face I
knew that'll be my last day there and I
was thinking to myself like why it has
happened to me Carter said she called
the police that day they asked for my
clothing and I gave him my favorite
Tommy Hilfiger shirt and that's what he
found
DNA evidence DNA evidence from our Kelly
on your shirt semen at the time charges
were not filed in Carter's case
according to Carter who shared the legal
documents ten months after the incident
she states that she signed a six hundred
and fifty thousand dollar settlement in
which Kelly denied any wrongdoing and
Carter agreed not to discuss any details
pertaining to Kelly
[Music]
then in 2008
Kelly released a song about having sex
with a woman who braids his hair that
was one of the hairstyles that I was
known for doing that I never did on him
we were on the l-shaped couch when the
incident happened
also according to Carter that song led
to her signing another confidential
settlement this time for $100,000 Kelly
again denied any wrongful conduct but
agreed to never perform the song or
include it in future albums in January
following the release of the lifetime
doc you Carter responded to a plea by
the current Cook County State's Attorney
Kimberly Fox for victims to call her
office actual witnesses and victims to
have the courage to tell their story
then Carter said she saw this explosive
interview with Kelly on CBS this morning
where he denied all accusations like it
should be a crime to publicly tell the
story that he's able to get on
television your life did seeing that
interview embolden you to want to speak
even more yes it's actually the reason
that I'm here
Kelly's defense attorney Steve Greenberg
told CBS News quote these allegations
were fully investigated by the police
and prosecutors and a decision was made
after evaluating all of the evidence not
to bring any charges as for Carter she
feels relieved since coming forward with
her story
this is a release I've been carrying
this since 2003 I don't want to be in a
public but this isn't my life if I died
tomorrow I know that I told the truth
this story is far from over of course
you can count on et to bring you all the
latest in the our Kelly case as it
breaks so make sure you subscribe to all
things et until next
I'm Hallie Stevens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]